I don't want my young children
indoctrinated with dangerous ideas.
Um,
and as time marches on,
I trust public education less and less.
I know that you have strong thoughts on
the danger of the devouring oedipal
mother who harms her child by protecting
them.
And that's certainly not what I aspire
to.
I wonder if in spite of your idea that
kids need to become tough and learn to
slay dragons,
if you have anything good to say about
the idea of homeschooling.
Well,
I don't have anything bad to say about
it.
I do know that the government has
recently taken moves to make it much
more difficult for people to homeschool
their children.
And it's not like five years.
I mean,
15 years ago I would have presumed that
the vast majority of people who were
homeschooled schooling their children
were to be viewed with skepticism.
Initially.
I'm not so sure about that anymore.
You know,
for example,
I was sent a poster today.
Someone sent me this link that they
found in the local junior high school
and one of the media pieces that were
recommended on this poster was a movie
called Hedwig.
And the angry inch now I thought that
was a terrible movie even though I'm
perfectly capable of enjoying bizarre
movies,
but.
So it's a bizarre movie,
that's for sure.
But I also thought it was a terrible
bitter movie.
Terrible and bitter.
Those are separate.
A movie can be bitter and be quite
great,
but it was a terrible movie and it was a
bitter movie.
But I can tell you one bloody thing
about that movie.
It's not required viewing for 12 year
old kids,
that's for sure.
So I think you have increasing reason to
be skeptical of the public education
system.
I also looked at the Elementary Teachers
Federation of Ontario's guidelines for
education from kindergarten to grade
eight.
And what that is in essence,
and I think I will do a video about it
in the relatively near future,
is a blueprint for transforming children
into social justice warriors.
Have basically says that it's like you
don't have to be a conspiracy theory to
read that.
I mean,
we have social justice tribunals in
Ontario and so the idea is,
well,
if you're going to get your children,
if you're going to get people to,
what would you say favor equity
properly?
Well then you better start teaching them
while they're young.
It's like maybe not.
So now you,
you asked that question properly because
he's say,
well,
the terrible education system,
the wonderful mother homeschooling,
right?
That's the danger.
It's like,
no,
because it might not be the wonderful
mother homeschooling.
It might be the pathological mother
using the pathology of the education
system as an excuse to get her talons
into her children.
Right?
Because that's certainly equally
possible or perhaps even more possible
because at least in the public
education,
there's some necessity for consensus.
So that's something that you have to be
very aware of and work to prevent.
Right.
And so I would say if you're going to do
that,
probably best not to do it on your own
and you need.
It's like you need a board of advisors
or something like that.
And so maybe it can't just be you and
you have to figure out,
well what,
what is the name and how are you going
to manage that and what makes you think
you can do it even if it's being done
badly publicly.
What makes you think you could do it
better?
I mean,
my general advice is,
and people have asked me this,
in fact,
I had a conversation with the guy who
was tiling my backyard this morning
about something his son had said to him
that he was taught at school recently,
which really made the tyler who had come
from a rather authoritarian country,
step back on his heels and think,
I'm not so sure I should be sending my
kid to public school anymore and maybe I
shouldn't be living in Toronto even,
you know.
But my general advice is keep an eye on
your kids and discuss with them what
they're learning and,
and help equip them with the tools to
not only to articulate their own
viewpoint in response to what they're
being taught now at.
The problem is you might not have the
time,
nor the ability to do that.
That's no simple thing and increasingly
if you're unwilling to have your
children participate in what is
increasingly indoctrination and not
education,
thanks to in no small part to the
Ontario Institute of Studies on
Education,
which is an institution that I
particularly despise because I think
that all it does is almost all it does
now is produce indoctrinates of
children.
It's not an easy,
it's not an easily easy problem to
solve,
so more more power to you wanting to put
your children in a situation where
they're not being indoctrinated,
but the alternative is very,
very complicated and difficult.
So
yeah,
thanks.